З 1 липня в Україні запрацює ринок землі.
Досі сільгоспземля не була товаром. Але більшість угідь фактично вже розпродана.
На цих кадрах СБУ ловить депутата-хабарника, якому "подякували" за виділення землі.
Ситуація, що трапляється нерідко. Це видима частина айсбергу тіньового земельного ринку.
Формально в Україні продавати сільськогосподарські землі не дозволяється вже 20 років.
Мораторій на продаж запровадили в січні 2001 року.
Але на практиці існує багато можливостей використовувати землю протиправно.
Існують агрохолдинги, які розпоряджаються десятками тисяч гектарів сільгоспугідь.
У Нацагентстві із запобігання корупції (НАЗК)  проаналізували та описали
типові тіньові схеми обігу сільськогосподарських земель.
Схема 1
Безоплатна приватизація
Кожен українець, згідно із Земельним кодексом,
має право безоплатно отримати в держави земельну ділянку,
не більше 2 гектарів, для ведення особистого селянського господарства.
Є квоти і для інших видів діяльності.
Але ця безоплатна приватизація добра лише в теорії.
Насправді виділення ділянок відбувалося непрозоро,
на всіх етапах приватизації отримували і отримують корупційний зиск
посадові особи. Крім того, НАЗК виявляло випадки підроблення рішень
органів місцевого самоврядування про виділення земель.
За даними Державної служби з питань геодезії, картографії та кадастру,
в приватну власність з державної через механізм безоплатної приватизації
були виведені земельні активи розміром у понад 700 тисяч гектарів.
Проте не існує жодного реєстру громадян, які отримали ці ділянки
за десятиліття приватизації. Частково інформація про нових власників
стане відомою лише після оцифрування паперових даних.
Фактично приватизація – "найефективніший" інструмент
для корупціонерів. Але є й інші.
Схема 2
Спільне володіння
Формально земля належить державному або комунальному підприємству,
фактично ж на ній працює приватна компанія чи агрохолдинг.
Для цього компанія та підприємство укладають договір про спільну діяльність.
На папері землю використовують спільно,
а в реальності компанія господарює сама.
Посадова особа, яка схвалює рішення про такий договір,
отримує корупційний зиск.
Цей договірний механізм цікавий тим, що не завжди передбачає
отримання доходу державним підприємством від "спільної діяльності"
і важко піддається контролю.
Хоча масштаби цієї сфери чималі - 800 тисяч гектарів землі,
або 2 відсотки загального земельного фонду України, є у розпорядженні
підприємств державної та комунальної власності.
При цьому переважна більшість підприємств
немає ресурсів для обробки та ефективного використання.
Схема 3
Самовільне захоплення
Фермер або приватне агропідприємство обробляє ділянку землі,
яка йому НЕ належить. Тобто, самовільно захоплює її.
Це практично неможливо без неформальної згоди тих чи інших
місцевих посадових осіб. А ті мають прикриття у кабінетах вище.
Штраф за самовільне захоплення та використання землі коливається
усього лише від 170 до 850 гривень для громадян-фізичних осіб
та до 1700 гривень - якщо це посадова особа.
Сума штрафу - необґрунтовано низька,
порівняно із зиском, який приносять ці протиправні дії.
Щоправда, є випадки, коли зловмисників навіть засудили за самовільне
захоплення землі. Але ця кримінальна відповідальність передбачена лише
за "значну шкоду законному власнику". І, на думку експертів, судова практика
у переважній більшості випадків дозволяє правопорушникам
уникати відповідальності. Обвинувачені посилаються на усні домовленості
з посадовими особами чи підприємствами-землевласниками.
А ті, у свою чергу, це завжди заперечують. Так справи заходять у глухий кут.
А за "вирішення питань" щодо закриття кримінальних проваджень
чиновники та правоохоронці отримують хабарі.
Припинена схема
Оренда на 49 років
Фізична особа могла законно отримати земельні угіддя в оренду,
терміном на 49 років. Без аукціонів, під фермерське господарювання.
У більшості випадків землю передавали у суборенду великим агрохолдингам.
Щоправда, відповідну норму закону в 2016 році скасували.
Але за період її дії, за оцінками НАЗК, за цією схемою виділили
близько 2 мільйонів гектарів сільгоспземлі.
Таким чином, попри мораторій з'явився прошарок великих латифундистів.
Найбільшими власниками земель в Україні називають
ексдепутата-регіонала Андрія Веревського, підприємця Юрія Косюка,
американського бізнесмена Джорджа Рора, оголошеного у розшук
підприємця Олега Бахматюка. Великими латифундистами вважають також
нардепів Сергія Лабазюка, Сергія Таруту та низку інших політиків.
Тіньовий ринок землі не може функціонувати без співучасті посадових осіб.
А це стимулює корупцію. Лише у 2020-му перевірки виявили майже 14 тисяч
тих чи інших правопорушень у земельні сфері.
Чому такі ситуації можливі?
На думку НАЗК, вагомою причиною поширення корупційних практик
є відсутність відкритого ринку землі та прозорих процедур
розпорядження землями державної та комунальної власності.